what I want to talk about in this video
are the notions of electronegative elect
electro negativity negative negativity
and a closely and a closely related idea
of electron affinity electron affinity
and they're so closely related that in
general if something has a high
electronegativity they have a high
electron affinity but what does this
mean well electron affinity is how much
does that atom attract electrons how
much does it like electrons does it want
nessa does it maybe want more electrons
electronegativity is a little bit more
specific it's when that atom is part of
a covalent bond when it is sharing
electrons with another atom how likely
is it or how badly does it want to hog
the electrons in that covalent bond or
what do I mean by hogging electrons so
let me make let me write this down so so
how badly badly wants to hog and this is
an informal definition clearly hog
electrons
keep-keep the electrons to spend more of
their time closer to them then to the
other party in the covalent bond and
this is how how how much they like
attract electrons or how how how much
affinity they have towards electrons so
how much they want want electrons and
you can see that these are very these
are very related notions this is within
the context of a covalent bond how much
electron affinity is there while this
you could think of it as a slightly
broader notion but these two trends go
absolutely in line with each other and
to think about to just think about
electronegativity make it a little bit
more tangible let's think about one of
the most famous sets of covalent bonds
and that's what you see in a water
molecule water as you probably know is
h2o you have an oxygen atom and you have
two hydrogen's
each of the hydrogen's have one valence
electron and the oxygen has we see here
in its outermost shell it has one two
three four five six valence electrons
one two three four five six valence
electrons and so you could imagine
hydrogen would be happy if it was able
to somehow pretend like it had another
electron then it would have an electron
configuration a stable first shell that
only requires two electrons the rest of
them require eight hydrogen would feel
hey I'm stable like helium if it could
get another electron and oxygen would
feel hey I'm stable like neon if I could
get two more electrons and so what
happens they share each other's
electrons this this electron could be
shared in conjunction with this electron
for this hydrogen so that hydrogen can
kind of feel like it's using both and it
gets more stable it stabilizes the outer
shell or it stabilizes the hydrogen and
likewise that electron could be can be
shared with the hydrogen and if the
hydrogen can kind of feel more like
helium and then this oxygen can feel
like it gets its it's a quid pro quo
it's getting something exchanged for
something else it's getting the electron
an electron it's sharing electron from
each of these hydrogen's and so it can
feel like it's that that it stabilizes
it similar to a similar to a neon but
when you have these covalent bonds only
in the case where they're equally
electronegative would you have a case
where maybe there shouldn't even there
what what happens in the rest of the
molecule might matter but when you have
something like this where you have
oxygen hydrogen they don't have the same
electronegativity oxygen likes to hog
electrons more that hydrogen does and so
these electrons are not going to spend
an even amount of time here I did it
kind of just drawing these you know
these valence electrons as these dots
but as we know the electrons are in this
kind of blur around around the around
the actual nuclei around the atoms that
make up the atoms and so in this type of
a covalent bond the electrons the two
electrons that this bond represents are
going to spend more time around the
oxygen than they are going to spend
around the hydrogen and these these two
electrons are going to spend more time
around the oxygen that are going to
spend around the
hydrogen and we know that because oxygen
is more electronegative and we'll talk
about the trends in a second this is a
really important idea in chemistry and
especially later on as you study organic
chemistry because because we know that
oxygens more electronegative and the
electrons spend more time and around
oxygen around hydrogen it creates a
partial negative charge on this side and
partial positive charges on this side
right over here which is why water has
many of the properties that it does that
it and we go into much more depth in
that in other videos and also when you
study organic chemistry a lot of the
likely reactions that are going to
happen can be predicted or a lot of the
likely molecules that form can be
predicted based on electronegativity and
especially when you start going into
oxidation numbers and things like that
electronegativity will tell you a lot so
now that we know what electronegativity
is let's think a little bit about what
is as we go through as we start as we go
through a as we go through a period as
say as we start in Group one and we go
to group and as we go all the way all
the way to let's say the halogens all
the way up to the yellow column right
over here what do you think is going to
be the trend for electronegativity and
once again one way to think about it is
think about the extremes think about
sodium and think about chlorine and I
encourage you to pause the video and
think about that assuming you've had a
go at it and it's in some ways the same
idea or it's a similar ideas ionization
energy an Electra something like sodium
has only one electron in this outermost
shell it would be hard for it to
complete that shell and so to get to a
stable state it's much easier for it to
giveaway that one electron that it has
so it can get to a stable configuration
like neon so this one really wants to
give away an electron and we said we saw
in the video on ionization energy that's
why this has a low ionization energy it
doesn't take much energy to in a gaseous
state to remove an electron from sodium
but chlorine is the opposite it's only
one away from completing its shell the
last thing it wants to do is give away
electron it
wants an electron really really really
really badly so it can get to a
configuration of argon so it can
complete its third shell so the logic
here is that sodium wouldn't wouldn't
mind giving away an electron while
chlorine really would love an electron
so chlorine is more likely to hog
electrons while sodium is very unlikely
to hog electrons so this trend right
here if when you go from the left to the
right
your electronegativity let me write this
you're getting more electronegative more
electro electronegative as you as you go
to the right now what do you think the
trend is going to be as you go down as
you go down in a group what do you think
the trend is going to be as you go down
well I'll give you a hint
think about think about atomic radii and
given that positive didn't think about
what do you think the trend is are we
going to get more or less
electronegative as we move down so once
again I'm assuming you've given a go at
it so as we know from the video and
atomic radii our atom is getting larger
and larger and larger as we add more and
more and more shells and so cesium has
one electron in in its outermost shell
and the sixth shell while say lithium
has one one electron everything here all
the Group one elements have one electron
its outermost shell
but that 55th electron that one electron
the atom of shown cesium is a lot
further away than the outermost electron
in lithium or in hydrogen and so because
of that it's it's it's it's well one
there's more interference between that
electron and the nucleus from all the
electrons in between them and also it's
just further away so it's easier to kind
of grab it off so cesium is is very
likely to give up is very likely to give
up electrons it's much more likely to
give up electrons than hydrogen so as
you go down a given group you're
becoming less less electronegative
electronegative so what what are based
on this what are going to be the most
electronegative of all the atoms well
they're going we're going to be the ones
that are in the top and the right of the
periodic table there
going to be these right over here these
are going to be the most electronegative
sometimes we don't think as much about
the noble gases because they aren't they
aren't really that reactive they don't
even form covalent bond because they're
just happy
well these characters up here they
sometimes will form covalent bonds and
when they do they really like to hog
those electrons and what are the least
electronegative sometimes called very
electro positive well these things down
here in the bottom left these over here
they have only you know in the case of
cesium they have one electron to give
away that would take them to a stable
state like like xenon or in the case of
these others in these group two elements
you might have to give away two but it's
much easier to give away two than to
gain a whole bunch of them and they're
big they're big atoms so those outermost
electrons are getting less attracted to
the positive nucleus so the trend in the
periodic table is you go from the bottom
left to the top right you're getting
more more electro electro negative